[Music]
hey everyone i'm lucy and i'm joined by
aaron flynn to talk a little bit about
nightingale so we saw a little bit of
the game awards we've seen some more at
uh summer game fest
aaron like what's the what's the
elevator pitch
uh so nightingale is a survival crafting
game set in the shared world gaslamp
fantasy universe where we've created
ourselves um and it brings a lot of
really interesting mechanics to survival
crafting and genre really like and the
thing we announced today was this thing
we call realm cards and so realm cards
let you as the player control portals
and because we have this complex
procedurally generated system to make
these realms and make these levels the
realm cards themselves influence and
control and help players have agency
over what they're going to see on the
other side of the portal so rather than
just a big vast open world
you go through these realms and these
realms are actually controlled and
manipulated by what you play in the
realm card system to open the portal and
go through so is there any kind of limit
on
how many realm cards i can play like
what what is the um
if i'm if i'm setting up
what am i what is it gonna look like yes
you're gonna get a few limitations there
so you get to play a variety of realm
cards you'll control your biome you'll
control um some of the major things
you'll see in the other side um you get
to control certain aspects of other
things like weather and stuff like that
and all that leads to changing the
experience and making the experience
exactly what you would want on the other
side and then in turn with that
different rewards and different
challenges or present themselves because
of what you've played
so how i mean how flexible is this
system then how often am i going to be
using the realm cards to change the
world that i'm playing
so every time you go through a portal
you're gonna get a chance to play round
cards um and the hope is that players
will find a lot of things to discover
and explore and
and have interest in in a realm and then
you know maybe after a few hours they
might decide to move on to the next
realm and see what's there for them
there might be quests to help you push
forward and things like that so that's
our hope we want to see players doing
that so lots to uncover in these realms
lots of mysteries lots to discover and
then you'll have a chance to earn more
realm cards and craft more of them and
then you'll go off to the next one try
something else so a lot of uh
customization a lot of like different
chances to try new things let's take a
look talk a little bit about kind of the
aesthetic you mentioned like gas lamp
why did you opt for that as a kind of
setting the aesthetic the tone yeah
great question so the gaslamp fantasy
idea came to us because originally we
wanted to do a fantasy game we knew that
much but some of us had made high
fantasy games like dragon age and things
like that but we decided that maybe a
contemporary fantasy setting was a
little better so something a little more
grounded in in what you recognize today
with certain outfits and certain um
certain weapons and gear and things like
that and so
in exploring that space we really like
this notion of the victorian era and
what it offered there so we got some of
the things to recognize you're going to
get typical shaped you know axes and
typical shaped knives like that at the
same time you have guns and things like
that but and we get really cool looking
cloaks and outfits and and helmets and
hats and everything and we just really
like that aesthetic and so from very
early in the project we embraced that
and embraced the architecture you get as
well you get all sorts of things that
you recognize as as being actual houses
or being actual um constructions
and we just fell in love with it early
in the early in the development was
there ever anything else on the table or
was it you know you kind of just saw
gaslight fans and you're like okay this
is it this is the kind of catch-all yeah
i think it was that actually i think we
didn't take very long before we after a
couple of concepts and a couple of ideas
going back and forth we just we just
said a lot so this is it we want this we
can bring this world to life
so you're gearing uh are you still
gearing for a 2022 release yeah that's
the plan um we're going to be having our
our play tests and closed alphas very
soon we want to get this trailer out now
we're gonna uh begin to prepare our
builds for that so stay tuned for more
on that front but uh yeah all all goes
well we'll be out in the next uh before
2022's over wow and so i
can i play solo or is this just you know
i can group up with a bunch of friends
kind of like valham style where you can
play by yourself but it really shines
when you're built yeah i think that's a
great way to say it you can definitely
play solo um you know it's not a game
for for particularly large groups so
it's not an mmorpg it's a game for small
groups friends
uh you know high trust relationships
where you'll know people and you bring
them in
invite them to your realm when they can
come explore around you can go to their
realm etc
and so that's really the sweet spot for
us this solo to small group play
so how many are you thinking about in
terms of small group like four we
haven't pinned it down yet but it should
be bigger than four a little bigger than
four i guess in terms of like you know
the original concept and we're gonna do
a bigger interview where we kind of
delve into this as well but it's like
where did where did the the seed of
nightingale kind of come from um so you
know the seed came from a few
conversations years and years ago um uh
our art director neil thompson and i had
both read a book called jonathan strange
and mr norrell by suzanna clarke she's
an english author and just fell in love
with it it was set in the napoleonic
wars and it was a story about the
rekindling of magic that came from the
fae and two wizards who had each
independently found magic again and had
each found different paths and fall
different paths to to harness it and use
it and we just loved that story we just
loved that um that concept and idea and
it kind of rolled around in the back of
niels and mai's mind for quite a while
and when we started inflection neil was
came along from from day one and we
started to bat the idea around there as
we thought about this game i thought
what if we had a setting like that and
so we take a lot of inspiration from
jonathan's strategy mr brown
well aaron is there anything else you
want to quickly say about nightingale
no this would be great thank you so much
i hope people enjoy and get to see a lot
more about what realm cards can do
because they're pretty flexible and it's
pretty awesome to watch players uh play
the game you can also play round cards
with your friends so you could play a
card and i could play card and then you
know we'll get to team up like that and
do things like that so it forms some
social gameplay as well which i really
like awesome thank you so much and for
more on nightingale make sure to stay
tuned to gamespot